[Music]
hey you guys what's going on yeah watch
watching pookie play with yeah watch out
there on the floor
throwing those little [ __ ] stuffed
animals in her mouth
you saw the mommy see finally i got his
[ __ ] ass to watch it durham
sent uh jenny the money uh to buy it and
jenny was able for like 15 bucks to get
all three movies in it yeah i got him
like in one box set yeah he sent me an
amazon gift card so thank you very much
dermot oh yeah yeah i saw the first one
it was good real good i liked the movie
i thought you might yeah i want to see
the other ones it's kind of like
it's a tentpole movie action movie
action adventure movie
kind of like a cross between
indiana jones it's very much like
indiana jones and maybe like uh
what was the one that had uh the rock in
it
uh where they go to the [ __ ] special
like uh jumanji jumaji kind of like
jumaji it's along those lines yeah the
tone is like jumanji
uh visually it looks like indiana jones
when they were making this movie the
director said he wanted to make it like
raiders of the lost ark meets jason and
the argonauts
yeah it did that yeah that's kind of
what he was going for i always think
more like jason the argonauts uh
that move those moves are kind of like
slow and epic like classic movies
this this is kind of fast paced with uh
good natured humor and a bunch of action
i'd say more like jumanji
but he said that before jumanji was
around i don't think machiamanji well
jumanji is uh the the one with the rock
in it was a remake of a movie from the
80s that had robin williams in it that
was like a board game yeah so it's like
the rock remake of jumanji yeah i like
that one too
i liked it yeah i did as well i haven't
seen the one from the 80s for a lot from
a long time yeah i don't think i ever
saw it
but the rock one i liked and i think we
saw the second one wouldn't it yeah we
saw the second one the second thing i
haven't seen the first jumanji from with
the rocket i saw the second one yeah it
was good
uh so uh so far man with we haven't seen
the other two yet but uh this one was uh
good real good
had the dude that played [ __ ] [ __ ]
batiatas from from uh
i had forgotten he even said this yeah
from spartacus john hannah that
characters that uh actor's name is i
think and yeah it was funny because like
when we were watching it because i
haven't seen this movie for probably
like 15 years or something and then when
we were what he came out and so i was
like oh my god it's spontaneous yeah
from the spartacus series and i was like
holy [ __ ] i totally didn't know that he
was there you got some epic kind of male
heroic roles and epic
male [ __ ] villain roles and comedic
villains and uh
uh hotties a lot of hotties in it
[ __ ] it starts off early on scantily
clad egyptian queens and all that yeah
yeah look good it's good the [ __ ]
special effects were good sets were good
score was good
jerry goldsmith that is yeah he's the
man he's going to say it's kind of like
an epic classic
razor lost arc type type movie
with uh cg the cg age is okay
uh but it was really good in its day
it's 1999 yeah um some of the cg
actually looks pretty good still yeah uh
you know some of it obviously you can
tell it's cg especially like in the
close-ups of imhotep like before he gets
all his like [ __ ] back
um you know it still looks like cg but
that's okay like i said like the whole
tone of the movie it's not realism
anyway is yeah it's just
it's meant to be just like a fun
enjoyable adventure and it's not taking
itself all that seriously and i think
that's a good you don't really see a lot
of
adventure movies like that anymore yeah
um after brazil lost ark there's a bunch
of uh kind of like decent adventure
knockoffs came aft came after it like uh
like in uh
what was the one rose uh [ __ ] [ __ ]
romancing the story romancing the stone
yeah i was i have said soft spot for
that movie yeah there was two of those
that was uh romancing the stone and
jewel of the nile i think it was the uh
was the sequel to that and then there
was a couple of other ones that had like
[ __ ]
uh [ __ ]
[ __ ] what was the what was the one
oh man i can't remember they had they
had several knockoffs after that this
one kind of reminds reminded me of one
of those
there's something a little bit about
the tone
in some ways kind of reminded me of like
jewel of the nile
i think it's because the the story is a
little
because it's kind of in mostly in one
place i don't know there was something
about it
it did kind of feel like a raiders lost
knock off
but not in a bad way
yeah i mean there's nothing wrong with
that i mean if you're gonna make an
homage or make a movie kind of like that
i mean you know that's a really good one
you could pick because that's an awesome
[ __ ] movie yeah slasher fred points
out national treasure yeah that's a good
one too i haven't seen that one or the
one with nicolas cage
yeah the whole treasure hunt yeah i do
kind of feel like i don't know there was
a lot of really good adventure movies
like in the 80s and then it seemed like
there was a little bit of a revival of
him in the 90s i think the issue
and we talk and i know that you liked
the tom cruise 2017 mummy
but one of the issues that i had with
that was that if you were going to go
sort of in that direction i can't even
though there was sort of humor in that i
felt like they took that it mostly took
itself too seriously the one i was
thinking of was fire walker remember
fire walker
it was kind of like indiana jones chuck
norris chuck norris was in it with the
uh that was terrible yeah
that's because was it louis jr yeah yeah
that was a terrible terrible yeah they
were they were taking them although i'm
sure it's hilarious yeah i remember
liking it but i thought but you know
what i thought that that movie was about
them weren't they going to hell or
something man i call it all kinds of
[ __ ] happened did it i don't remember it
was it's been a long time since it was a
ludicrous that's it yeah i remember
ludicrous over the top
raiders of the lost ark knock off they
had chuck norris and that lewis junior
guy was wisconsin jr yeah
and i remember being at the time being
like what
it was even more [ __ ] up than uh
than [ __ ] uh big trouble in little
china
big trouble but big trouble
is a good movie yeah
yeah but i'm just talking about it but
he was also ludicrous a big trouble with
a little chunk yeah but it was ludicrous
in a good way yeah i kind of feel like
fire walker was not trying to be
ludicrous it was just uh ludicrous
accidentally
which kind of makes it so bad it's good
but like i said i haven't seen it a long
time in a long while i just remember it
being like completely
completely stupid and that i couldn't
believe how stupid it was
but so okay so one thing i didn't know
because remember i think when we talked
about the 2017 mummy movie which like i
said you like it and i didn't like it
but
i didn't realize
that you know the whole universal and
they were trying to do the dark universe
uh kind of thing that that was like the
reboot what i didn't realize to the i
didn't realize the extent of it they'd
actually been trying to get that [ __ ]
off the ground since 1987. and remember
how i said that it's like i really would
have liked it if they'd gone in a more
overtly horror direction that's exactly
what they were trying to do
in the 80s
the first thing they did they said okay
we want to do a remake which this the
brendan fraser uh mummy movie is a loose
remake of the 1932 it's 1932 right 1932
mummy with boris karloff um it's a
similar story they changed it some but
it's kind of a loose remake
so what they wanted to do was they
wanted to do that and it was going to be
like a whole
remaking all the universal monster
things but they were gonna be more
overtly horror movies in 1987 they
pitched the idea to george romero
and george romero actually like kind of
wrote a screen treatment and [ __ ] like
that and it was actually supposed to be
like low budget like 10 million um
and then so like george romero was
involved for a while and then that
didn't go anywhere then they gave it to
clive barker so like i said they're
going in a more horror direction clive
barker because he's clad barker uh wrote
something that was weird as [ __ ] and
they were like yeah we can't do that um
with a bunch of like sex and [ __ ] in it
and they're like no uh i don't know why
they asked clyde bark because you know
he's gonna climb barker it up it's gonna
be perverse um yeah cause that's just
that's his bag man that's what he does
um and they also had joe dante uh
involved for a while and john sales was
in there so they had like all these
mcgarris i think uh took a stab at it
so they had like all of these horror
guys and they were kind of trying to go
like i said in a more low budget horror
direction
and then it just kind of like went
you know i think george romero got back
involved in like 94 or something like
that he was going to do it something
more like a zombie movie but they were
still trying to like keep the budget low
but then finally finally they get to a
point where they're like okay maybe
we'll do it more like an adventure movie
and then finally they were like okay
let's do like a big budget kind of thing
with it not a huge but i think it was 80
million this cost to make
um and it's weird because i kind of feel
like when it came out they didn't think
it was going to do that well it was
actually supposed to come out like right
around the same time as star wars the
phantom menace and they're like okay
yeah we can't do that because we'll get
[ __ ] creamed so they actually like
push the um they they release it a
little bit earlier than they were going
to and it was like a huge success it
ended up being making like 400 something
million dollars
so which is why there were a couple
sequels there was a spin-off like
scorpion king and i think they even did
a cartoon show and [ __ ] like that
so
i think this was absolutely the right
tone to take at the time
the guy that directed this steven
summers he directed this one and he
directed the second one but i don't
think he did the third one
he also directed van helsing
which i i didn't love that came out
after this
and um he also did gi joe the rise of
cobra which i haven't seen i heard it
was good um yeah i've heard mixed
reviews of it i think a lot of g.i joe
fans from the old cartoons liked it
i'll get around to seeing it one of
these days i should note too that he
also directed the 1998 film deep rising
which i reviewed not too long ago like
last month i think on my monster march
yeah because it's like a just a fun
action monster movie so i feel like that
movie
had kind of the same tone as this one
where that one was just that one was set
in the present day and everything like
that but it was like a monster movie but
just like big dumb fun
you know with some comedic relief and
then big monsters like eating people you
know what i mean so they kind of went
that direction it's weird because i kind
of feel like most of the original
scripts i guess because they were trying
to keep the budget low um they didn't
want to make it a period piece they
wanted it set in contemporary time so
it's like so it would have something to
do with like
uh you know reincarnation or some [ __ ]
like that so it was usually like based
around a museum and they had a
sarcophagus there and then you know the
they somebody wakes the mommy up and
chaos ensues
but once they decided to go in a more
big budget direction then they said okay
we'll make it a period piece so they
said it in the 1920s you know right
around the time that in real life howard
carter was finding king tut's tomb and
all that kind of stuff so i think that
was like kind of a cool
uh thing to do you were asking last
night while we were watching it did they
shoot this in egypt no
it's morocco morocco it's morocco i
lived in egypt for almost a year so i
was a little i was like that kind of
looks like egypt but it's not rocky
enough i mean it's close
but i mean all the [ __ ] in the desert
that is the actual sahara desert they
did shoot it there um but the scenes
that are supposed to be cairo are
actually uh marrakesh that was i was in
sinai which is that that leads out into
cairo and it's
most of it looks like [ __ ] mars
i got pictures of it looks like mars i
was kind of thinking that when we were
watching because every time i see um
any anything like that was like egypt or
the desert or eat that part of the world
it does kind of look like look look like
rocks everywhere i actually kind of
thought of that we were watching the
movie last night too even though that's
morocco and not egypt but like i said
same part of the world the same part of
the world um but yeah so also arnold
vaslu plays imhotep and he was just in
the two dark man sequels that we talked
about just the other day he did a good
job he was epic in this i mean it's
weird
yeah he's not in it a lot because most
of the mummy action is him being all
[ __ ] up looking at cg
but he did do all the motion capture so
like all um you know they put him in the
suit it wasn't a stunt man his face is
in it
yeah they put him in the suit and he
kind of like wandered around girlfriend
was smoking
got killed and turned into a mummy
well she yeah well the whole plan was
that way a long time ago in the city of
the dead
i mean him and her like they conspired
and they killed the pharaoh because they
were [ __ ] around right yeah and then
she's like hey i got a plan um i'll kill
myself and then we'll go to the city of
the dead and you resurrect me and then
it'll be everything will be fine but uh
yeah that's not how that and you had to
make movies back then
they got every guy's attention in that
[ __ ] early on they just show that
girl walking through there in that
[ __ ] gauzy ass [ __ ] egyptian queen
outfit just looking titty nasty
yeah okay all right this movie's gonna
be all right
you always see a few seconds but then
the movie just keeps getting better
more action more action more action
so uh yeah they knew right they knew
back in the day they knew how to make a
tentpole movie
every dude [ __ ] okay eyes on the
screen boys okay
that's all you have to show the movie so
what tom is saying is that every like
note to filmmakers from now on every
movie should just start with like a shot
of tits yeah tits and ass and then every
woman and then it doesn't even matter
what the movie is about
they'll just watch the rest
you're gonna be paying attention
dudes are simple creatures yeah
but yeah and honestly i mean yeah okay
but i mean you're gonna have to you have
to draw the men in early it's either
[ __ ] like something about a mad max
fury road where there's just instant
[ __ ] suspense in action or sex one or
two it's got to be
something that'll immediately get your
attention and they kind of did a little
bit of both with this one they um the
psychology and the they understood human
psychology through this whole movie
it had a real good pace to it it didn't
have any slow spots
it didn't really it just kind of went
from thing to thing and like i said it
had it was funny but it wasn't like
overly zany
romance in it but it wasn't so sappy to
throw the guys out of it yeah the the
romance was superficial and fun and
light and they just showed cute
librarian girl
and she was a real likeable character i
liked that she everybody in this was
likable even though a lot of the
characters were like kind of terrible
and like selfish and stuff but
um they were still kind of lovable
despite themselves it doesn't wallow in
any one emotion for very long it just
gets the point across and then moves on
and that's kind of a pacing i noticed
that the average guy likes i like that
pacing
don't get bogged down in any of these
emotions just tell me what it is okay
that's it on to the next one okay that's
what it is all right let's go oh that
was this oh that happened oh that was
great oh and then this happened and then
that happened oh [ __ ] you made it you
made it okay look oh [ __ ]
like a ride
it's one it's one of those uh it's well
on a ride movie yeah it's kind of
something like where the stakes just
keep getting higher and higher you know
what i mean it's like first you kind of
have these two
rival groups of archaeologists you know
you have brendan fraser's character and
the librarian and the brother and
they're kind of trying to go and find
this city of the dead um
what is it called hamanoptra
um so they're going and then there's a
bunch of like kind of
raucous like cowboy americans yeah and
on the other side and they're trying to
get there so the first part of it is
like them seeing who can get there first
like it's a competition
and then when they get there then they
have to like contend with uh the magi
who are like where the guards were
guarding the tomb because there's some
bad [ __ ] going on here and you don't
want to like release the [ __ ] curse
or whatever they're just like whatever
don't want to hear it we're just like
looking for treasure my only part of it
my problem i had problems with this is i
like the mage but they they made the
magi muslims magi are [ __ ]
zoroastrians as far as i'm concerned
well i mean but the thing about it is
that maybe like most people probably
don't know what a zory astronaut is so i
think maybe they just wanted to stick
with something that more people knew
what it was generic right interestingly
the guy that played um the head magi
what was the character's name i think
was artist bae
the guy that played him he was supposed
because you know how you had those like
tattoos on his face yeah he was supposed
to be in the script he was supposed to
have tattoos all over his body but i
think the director of the producers
thought that dude was too good looking
and they didn't want to cover him
entirely with ink yeah
[ __ ] kind of desert
warrior robes and [ __ ] these
tattoos look like mark a cane or
something you know on his head
and uh like something out of the bible
guns he had a damn um
a [ __ ] lewis gun
they took off the back of a [ __ ]
downed biplane he was out there [ __ ]
shooting those mummies up
lewis guns got it you know you guys
wouldn't understand what it is it's
but yeah so it's like then they have to
contend with them they're like hey don't
[ __ ] around you're gonna [ __ ] around and
find out whatever and then
um
it so happens that they find the book of
the dead and then they find all the
you know the uh jars that have all of um
hotep's uh guts in it
and they accidentally read from the
black book well you know they don't
really believe in the curse so they do
that and then obviously imhotep comes
back from the dead and he starts going
after every single one of the people
that took one of the jars that had some
of his guts in it and also
he takes some of their
uh
stuff as well like the first guy he
takes his eyes and his tongue
i mean i have to say
you know i hadn't seen this in a long
time
for a pg-13
this kind of hearkened back to like i
said sort of like temple of doom type
[ __ ] where it's like a pg-13 family
movie but there's some pretty gory [ __ ]
happens in this they're pushing the
boundaries they really are like you know
like like i said a dude gets like people
get their tongues cut out like their
eyes poked out um one dude gets you get
to see him like eaten alive by scare
beetles
so
so some kind of [ __ ] up [ __ ] happens
in this i mean like i said it's it's
sort of like a video game it's not like
a torture porn or anything like that
it's fantasy but i was actually
surprised at how many people get [ __ ]
killed in this movie for something
that's kind of like like i said
ostensibly a family movie
uh slasher fred said there was a movie
in the 90s called encino man yeah i
remember that where fraser played a
caveman frozen in ice uh yeah in fact i
think that encino man was the first time
that i saw brendan fraser in a movie
fun fact i was over in the uk in the 90s
and i was in a video store and i noticed
that encino man over there is just
called california man because nobody
knows where the [ __ ]
well they don't know where the stadium
is
so it's kind of like they just changed
it to california man which is fine uh
adriana c says clive barker depraved sex
mummy would have loved to seen that i
honestly i'm really curious to see what
clive barker
would have done with it
it would have been
strange and possibly wonderful
although uh cloud barker's all of his
books and stories are amazing
movie adaptations are kind of hit or
miss of his stuff because he's so
imaginative that it's really hard to
translate his vision in a way that's not
[ __ ] up you know what i mean this one
i'll go with this version i mean but
yeah i mean
yeah
movie classic big action flick
fun for the whole family you know that
it's just kind of a universal movie that
you can show to anyone they tend to make
good money so this probably did real
well yeah i said it made over 400
million yeah which is actually nothing
nowadays but but it only costs 80
million
nowadays they want to make a billion and
[ __ ] yeah that's freaking creepy yeah
but i mean in 1999
this was like a big
deal
and it's just funny because i feel like
when they were first doing um
the sort of you know how they show like
test audiences the original stuff um
they didn't the executives didn't think
it was gonna do that well because
a lot of audiences in 1999 associated
the title the mummy with like creaky old
horror movies and they just thought it
was gonna be dumb
um
but
to their credit the executive's like no
we're keeping the title
because this is technically a remake of
that movie even though they've changed a
lot obviously but
i guess whatever the test audiences were
smoking that wasn't because this
actually ended up doing really well and
honestly it did i think it was number
one for like several weeks until phantom
menace came out and sort of like knocked
it to number two but you know it
actually did really well and like i said
it's easy to see why this is a real
crowd-pleasing
movie it's just
it's like a popcorn flick it's super fun
it's just like a big dumb adventure you
don't really have to like concentrate on
it too hard i mean it's better if you
concentrate on it but it has these
amazing big sets there's monsters
there's gun fights there's humor there's
like kind of some there's like you said
a little bit of romance but not too much
where you're like oh barf yeah yeah you
know because i do that too
you know don't wallow in the [ __ ] right
it's you know you all like each other
okay
[Laughter]
yeah it moves along at a good clip and
like i said the the stakes keep getting
higher and higher because
as
impotent like starts getting his body
back
as he starts to kind of be fully
resurrected he's bringing down like the
you know the plagues of egypt which is
kind of a big [ __ ] deal and if he
gets
you know his whole thing and he
resurrects his love
then he's gonna like [ __ ] up the whole
entire planet so there's really like a
high
stakes sort of thing where
you know they really have to like stop
this supernatural creature and they
don't really know how to do it other
than like shooting at it because what
the [ __ ] else are you gonna do right um
so you know so i really like that i also
really liked the the character that uh
rachel wise plays in this you know the
librarian
because i like that they made her kind
of like
she's kind of like
goofy and klutzy
but
she's really really smart and honestly
like her
knowledge is kind of what saves
everybody's butts
even though i think it's funny how the
the archaeologist the head archaeologist
on the on the opposite like the american
team he's kind of like why are they
listening to a woman like she doesn't
know anything and basically like she had
read all the [ __ ] so she knew exactly
like how to [ __ ] open the tomb up and
[ __ ] like that yeah but yeah i just like
i said i saw this
god
probably back in the early 2000s
sometime or mid-2000s i think somebody
loaned it to me and i remembered like
really really liking it and
um it was just like really really fun
like watching it again now like i said
we have all three
so
i guess you you want to like watch the
whole trilogy you liked it enough to
like watch it i've heard that the other
two are not as i mean are not as good
obviously like the first ones but that's
always the case
so we'll kind of see
how it goes with that but i'm glad you
finally got to
see it because it just i don't know why
i thought of it because we had watched
the dark man movies and that had arnold
vossler in it and i was like oh yeah he
was imhotep in the mummy and then i was
like oh tom would probably really dig
that and then when you said you hadn't
seen it i was kind of like oh well
probably so cruz mommy and i liked
everybody laughed at me
because it's a because it's a bad movie
and it's not even bad in like a fun way
it's just bad and oh my god please kill
me it just had all those damn monsters
in it man i liked it
i liked mr hyde didn't it that was
honestly that was the only thing that i
liked about that one that was the only
thing dr jekyll be talking and all of a
sudden you start flipping to mr hyde and
he's and i'm going right along with him
i'm like yeah yeah i feel you on the
opportunity like yeah are you okay
yeah
you know i feel that dude i know because
that's exactly what you're talking about
yeah because i was yeah he was a lot
like you actually yes i know exactly
there's times when i [ __ ] injected
some stuff myself i get just like that
[Laughter]
testosterone will do that too well i've
told you it's like that character is
kind of like your that or the classic um
the one scene in the shining where jack
torrance is going down toward the goal
room
i was like oh my god it's you stanley
kubrick knows exactly
[Laughter]
at the right time
he's not like that all the time but
sometimes he is like that but yeah so
well i knew where i first saw it before
i ever saw that i was watching the
nature program yeah where
the they were doing a program on
wolverines and they were [ __ ] oh yeah
they were doing that's your spirit
animal telegraph telegraphic or
telephoto lens on a wolverine walking
around looking at the trees going down
he was just mad
they said that you know well that the
males get that way at certain times of
the
breeding site of the month yeah and they
just attack [ __ ] random tree bark and
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
like i hear you man
get that tree
get that tree you know i was like yeah i
know exactly tommo
although i have to say like even though
pookie is a girl but she does that
sometimes too like if you if you do
stuff that she doesn't like she kind of
walks around going oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah like if she's mad yeah if you
won't let her do something she wants
right so i guess it's just like kind of
an animal thing yeah but yeah so i i
don't know i think the difference
between
the tom cruise one the thing about the
tom cruise one i don't even [ __ ]
remember what the hell happened in that
story what the [ __ ] even happened in it
i don't even remember hugo said he liked
the tom cruise one too
i know some people did
it had it was a different game on it it
was kind of it kind of reminded me of a
slightly better more complete and more
complete version of like league of
extraordinary gentlemen remember that
movie yeah yeah yeah it was kind of like
that they were bringing all the damn
universal monsters together into one
movie and i guess they were going to
make several of them but it just didn't
work out because they were kind of
trying well they were trying to do a
marvel extended universe
like the mcu which it felt a little
shoehorned yeah and i just kind of felt
like i was like if you're gonna make a
mummy movie make a mummy movie like you
can put some of that other [ __ ] in there
if you want to but i just felt like
there wasn't enough concentration on
that and then jammed so much stuff into
one movie that's yeah that's i think
that was what so a lot of it was just
like a slog and i was just like this
doesn't even have anything to do with
mummy [ __ ] and it's like i don't know
why this is even in here now when the
mommy was a cute goth girl yeah
which is cool but it's like she looked
really good she did i liked the look of
it i just didn't like
i wanted it to be either more horrory or
more like this one more like adventurey
and fun with a real like legit like
ancient egyptian vibe to it don't ask me
why tom cruise was in it
uh that was a little miscasting i don't
know why he was in it i don't know
either he was supposed to be kind of
like he wasn't
he was he wasn't a commando was he he
was a part of some kind of a
i mean it wouldn't shock me if he was
because he always has to be some kind of
like super secret agent spot yeah
something yeah and he's
he can't just be like a regular regular
dude
you know it didn't really make sense
that's what i liked about this one
because brendan fraser was just like a
regular dude he was kind of like a thief
kind of a little bit of a scoundrel like
a han solo type character mommy tom
cruise mommy movie would have made a lot
more sense if he was just an indiana
jones type guy yeah if he was uh and he
was a little scary or yeah it's like
someone that's a little like morally
gray but still like kind of likeable
tomb raider right like a male version of
tomb i think brendan fraser did such a
good job in this because he's kind of
like like i said he's a little bit of a
scoundrel like he steals [ __ ] he's like
kind of getting in trouble
um he's a little bit of a lunk head but
he's you still like him though he's
still like really lovable because he's
still like deep down he's a good guy you
know what i mean you know i'm gonna see
commandos beyond the age of 35 people
been there that's what i mean that's and
so i kind of think that while i'm you
know the 2017 one could have been a good
move but maybe maybe tom cruise's ego
kind of got in the way of the production
he wants to be 35 forever yeah and like
i said he always has to be like some big
badass and [ __ ] like that and i really
don't think i do kind of remember that
there was maybe some sort of attempts at
humor in that one but it just didn't
work because i kind of felt like it was
trying to take itself too seriously and
it was trying to be like a big action
movie like a marvel movie yeah instead
of just letting it be its own thing like
i said either be like a mummy horror
movie or be like this one be like an
adventure mummy movie yeah with scary
[ __ ] like skeleton
with swords and [ __ ] when you're dealing
with tom cruise's age bracket you can go
mercenary 40 and 50s in some of those
movies you know arnold schwarzenegger
and his mercenary crew from from
predator one i think i think arnold was
either 41 or 42 at the time and he was
looking great he looked great most of
those guys were 40s early 40s 30s late
30s around that
uh but when you start talking about
steven seagal
okay
mercenary in his [ __ ] late 60s and
[ __ ] 300 and something pounds
needs a [ __ ]
body double to walk up and down stairs
you're not fooling anybody
you are not those guys aren't around
they're in other lines of work at that
at those ages
you know
and then [ __ ] that one mercenary for
justice
[ __ ] or whatever the [ __ ] personally
yeah they're all called bad
you had the guy who was he he was think
he was a real admiral or general for a
while there he was in under siege he
shows up in it and to play the role of a
general and he's like [ __ ] in his 80s
that you're not going to see that either
80 year old generals in the [ __ ]
field just no
there's a limit to all this
it's a young man's game
i didn't know this actually but adriana
just said rachel wise who was in this
movie playing the love interest uh she's
actually married to daniel craig in real
life oh really well there you go okay uh
hugo also said the only good movie like
in this whole like universal reboot kind
of thing was dracula untold i'll agree
with that i really liked that as well i
i liked that as well because they went
in a more like it was kind of actiony
and [ __ ] but it went like in a more
horrory type of direction
again because it was about like vlad the
impaler we have it don't we yeah i got
it on blu-ray didn't i i think i thought
sophie sent it did yeah
i liked mommy too i don't give a [ __ ] i
liked mommy it's all right it wasn't as
good it
well it was different than dracula i'm
told i had another i think i have a
couple of other ones from that series
that are okay
i just don't remember yeah what the
other ones were
well it didn't really go anywhere i mean
like i said they
because the the 2017 one was like so
poorly received not only by critics but
people didn't like go see it either
i just i don't know like i said i'm only
going to be on mcu it's hard
yeah if you're just trying to do the
same thing with that you're trying to
like you know cram like a square peg
into a round hole there are two
completely different things i don't
think it's a crazy idea to do an
extended universe with the monsters but
not at this time i think it's better if
you're gonna do that if you're gonna
remake the universal monster movies fine
but
i you can maybe make them loosely
connected but don't try to cram them all
into the same time period or the same
because the stories are like so wildly
different yeah there's something about
the universal movies they were black and
white
yeah and and it was like so get that
[ __ ] it was so creepy if they were
huge widescreen epic hd black and white
movies with some badass [ __ ]
badass [ __ ] um cg but they're like
sepia tone but it's like you're looking
at an old movie from the 30s see i would
watch that but it's like a movie they
could never [ __ ] make with the right
with creepy [ __ ] and it's almost like a
30s style acting and stuff they'd
probably go over a lot better
actually i want to see that i want to
see those
i would i would totally watch that i
know maybe a lot of people wouldn't but
i would completely i would be completely
on board with it it would look like a
movie that they could only dream of in
the 30s
well look i mean for kind of an analog
to that look at what um what do they
call the hp lovecraft appreciation set
or whatever and you know how i think
that's what they're called but they make
their own like kind of low budget
adaptations and they make them look like
the movies look like they came out back
when the story came out like from the
1920s and they're really cool call it
couture like color cthulhu cthulhu was
like king kong claymation yeah like they
did one like that and then they did what
was the other one that they did that we
saw i can't remember what it was but
yeah they did it kind of like old but
but i just kind of feel like if you're
gonna the universal monster movies
i felt like if they were gonna remake
them i'm kind of glad that the
this one the 1999 mummy just went in a
more like action indiana jones type of
direction and just made it like i said
it still had monsters and scary [ __ ] but
they went like whole hog with the
mystical adventure type [ __ ] i think
that was a good direction because if
you're going to go like in a horror
horror direction like you said i think
that they should go
more like the old ones like in tone
don't try to don't try to do like the
2017 mummy movie where you're trying to
make it like a big action
movie like a superhero movie because
it's just not the same thing they would
they would look black and white and real
[ __ ] scary and like look like funeral
art
and i would have it like animated kind
of like 300
yeah 300 was yeah
but it would look like just gothic
horror
that would be [ __ ] rad yeah like that
that would be fun yeah when you i would
love that when you see frankenstein it's
boris carlos frankenstein it's that
just worse yeah i'm talking about yeah
and with and he does more stuff
um
the creature in black lagoon would be
looked just like the originals but it
would be like a real living creature but
it would look like
looked like it was kind of
much better like it was made in the 30s
but much better than they could make in
the 30s like like 300
yeah because nowadays i mean back then
like i said they you know everything was
sort of more stagey they didn't really
have
um you know they didn't like have a lot
of the same budget or the same
technology that we have nowadays so you
could do it like that but you could kind
of like
yeah amp it up so imagine if you did the
black cat
and you had another 20 minutes in there
and there was necrophilia and all those
[ __ ] bodies down see i would watch
that and then weird [ __ ] of what he was
trying to do with karen and stuff and
weird because there was some stuff that
was got to be caught it had me cut out
yeah and then stuff with the actual cat
didn't wasn't the cat didn't the cat
originally wasn't that supposed to be
a sp a spirit or a soul of one of the
women in the black cat
yes it was cut out right um it was
something like that or it was kind of
like or it was the spirit of satan or
something i don't remember what yeah i
thought he was like a spirit familiar or
something yeah i think
you have to put all that in there
because you now have the budget because
it's it's well and now you can get away
with putting all kind of like [ __ ] up
[ __ ] in movies you couldn't back then
and hair pelzick's [ __ ] house we
could be even more epic
yeah see that'd be great somebody needs
to [ __ ] i know well that's the thing
they've done so many
movie versions of the black cat as in
the edgar allan poe story but that movie
the black cat with boris karloff and
bella lugosi that really didn't have
[ __ ] all to do with the edgar allan poe
story but it's its own thing but that's
awesome yeah so somebody needs to remake
that dracula on toll was close from what
i remember but i would have done it
in black and white or maybe like blue
and white or sepia tone type
something just something that's just
real real real creepy
and maybe there's color sometimes like
blood is red that type of stuff
but yeah it's black and white maybe
certain things will be colored but it's
basically a black and white movie to
kind of so almost kind of like you're
talking about something almost like sin
city
where it was like a black and white but
then they had sometimes there was color
sometimes it was red or yellow but it
was kind of like like a comic book
simmer like sin city yeah yeah you you
got it right but i would just take i
would take that old retro
horror from the 30s they take that
[ __ ] motif and just maximize that
yeah got the [ __ ] out right
that's what it would be like i think
that would be really awesome
and honestly if you
uh if you did it right and you did like
a really good compelling story and [ __ ]
like that i think i don't think there's
any reason why a lot of people wouldn't
go see that yeah you know what i'm
saying if it was like creepy that's the
way [ __ ] conan should be
like conan needs to be remade yeah but
you do it like 300
but it looks like a frank rosetta yeah
see that would be super good yeah
adriana says was boris karloff the
original mummy yeah yeah yeah and i've
never seen the original i've seen i've
seen it it's good i've seen photographs
but i haven't seen that movie we have to
see it and i think i mentioned this
before but i think
that i like boris karloff's mummy makeup
better than the frankenstein makeup i
think it's still jack pierce i think was
still um still he's the one that did the
frankenstein makeup i think he did the
mummy makeup as well i think it looks
fantastic still and that movie is like
[ __ ]
almost 100 years old at this point and
that mummy makeup looks amazing adriana
if you haven't seen the black cat with
boris karloff bellagos you see it it's
it's we reviewed it a little bit well
domain you can see it for free
on youtube oh and oh my gosh hugo says i
forgot about this one some of the
attempts were uh benicio del toro's wolf
man
yeah i forgot about that i remember i
think i saw that in the theater and i
remember thinking so i mean i love
benicio del toro anyway um
i don't remember that much about it i
remember liking it at the time but not
loving it um but at some point i'll have
to like re-watch it but and see uh and
another one was werewolves which was
really bad i don't think i saw that one
but i did see the benicio delta or a
wolf man but yeah so they have tried to
do them
it's just that
i feel like if you're gonna do them like
decide ahead of time it has to be
planned out and plan it out and have one
person like or just a group of people
work on all of them and they have like a
singular vision yeah that they're all
gonna look like this yeah that's how and
that's that's how star wars was supposed
to be done yeah how everything is in mcu
the series has its own style and all the
all the
all the movies have to interlock with
each other and they all have to have a
similar tone and they all have to be
able to be compatible you can't just do
one at a time piecemeal and
probably and then they don't have
anything to do with one another like i
said i i don't like that i kind of want
them to be all thematically
you can make them different stories just
like they are yeah but make them all
look thematically similar you can do
little different things depending on if
it's creature from the black lagoon or
dracula or whatever but make them all
kind of look like they're a set you know
oh and yeah i forgot about this one too
mr88 says there was a robert de niro
frankenstein that's right i remember
that and kenneth branagh played dr
frankenstein right i think i saw that in
the theater also i remember that one
being not too bad
um and it was very very close to the
book which you don't usually see because
the universal one from the original i
mean that
is kind of close to the book but they
cut a lot of the book out
you could do a bella lugosi style
dracula nowadays it would just blow the
original away if you had the right act
or two but i would do it that same way
like i just talked about it like be all
black and white movie but some some
color like sim city you gotta have the
right actor to [ __ ] carry that role
that baylor did and then be a dude that
looked like that because that that was
based on stage play that particular
movie
and there wasn't much you could do with
special effects and a lot of stuff's cut
out you know like him transforming into
things and
transforming into clouds of bats and
wolves and everything you know you could
do a lot more now yeah a lot more and
you could uh put more female characters
in there like the
like mina and [ __ ] her friend and her
friend lucy lucy and all them because
that's not in the bellas version of the
movies there is no no two dracula movies
are the same they're all different
but there's a whole there's a guy who
did a whole video on them yeah it's
james from cinema massacre right hell
none of them are the same it's they're
all just kind of he wanted he was trying
to determine which one was the closest
to the actual novel yeah and uh it was
actually a tie between a bbc version
from
the 70s or 80s i can't remember and the
francis ford go blue one which is crazy
because the francis ford coppola one
adds a bunch of [ __ ] that wasn't in the
book but
all the stuff that's in there is like
way more book accurate than most of the
other ones because like you said the
bella lugosi one the universal that was
based on a stage play which was based on
the book um so a lot of the stuff was
kind of like cut out and yeah straw dog
78 says francis ford coppola did bram
stoker's dracula right all the effects
were on camera yeah if you're gonna do
it do it like that like make it i like
that he committed to
we're gonna do the special effects in
this movie like they would have done
them back then and it looks great but
like with mod you know they use some
modern [ __ ] too but cause it's in color
but they used all the same techniques
back then and it's like it looks amazing
and those special effects don't date
because
they're stylized
you know so i think if you're gonna go
to like do it that way you could
definitely do it that way
uh adriana said i watched the black cat
with karl f and lugosi i loved it
their interaction and banter was amazing
plus their charisma and magnetism yeah
that's definitely all that badassery in
one movie
i lo honestly i loved boris karloff in
that he was just like that that smirk
that he had and it was just kind of like
and that that [ __ ] castle he built
that's [ __ ] that was the [ __ ] too
it's a futuristic castle like something
out of jetsons yeah it's in the 1930s
yeah sliding doors and intercoms and
radios just oh look a radio yeah
well it's you know it was a big deal
yeah but anyway all right so
so yeah the mummy from 1999 a much more
successful remake like i said it's not
really a horror movie it's more like
just a fun adventure movie but has some
horror elements monsters and [ __ ] like
that and i think if you're gonna go in
that direction they went whole hog and i
think it was really really successful
like i said it's just like a fun
[ __ ] popcorn movie now tonight we're
gonna watch
the second one the mummy returns because
like i said i got the whole trilogy so
we will talk about that one tomorrow and
then uh we'll watch the third one and
then we'll see how that goes um we don't
have i don't have the spin-off which was
the scorpion king with the rock in it i
remember that
spin off off this uh yeah i think it
came out after i think it came out 2008
i want to say maybe earlier i can't
remember 2004 i don't remember what it
was but um yeah so that's like a spinoff
in this series but there were three and
then they did the scorpion king i think
the scorpion king might be a prequel
to this if i'm not mistaken so we don't
have that one but i have the three so
we're going to talk about
those
all right so we will be back
tomorrow evening talking about uh the
mommy returns so thanks everybody for
dropping by have a good rest of your
evening and we will see you guys again
tomorrow